>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Good evening, ladies
and gentleman.
Bienvenidos.
Welcome to the Pickford,
the very intimate,
lovely, beautiful Pickford.
We're very glad to have you here.
I am Marie Arana.
And I am here to welcome
you on behalf
of the Librarian Hispanic
Initiative.
This is an initiative that was
begun by the Librarian of Congress,
James Billington, who
just about a year ago.
[ Applause ]
Just about a year ago,
Dr. Billington decided
that an organization was
needed, an initiative was needed
with a working group behind it to
better serve the Hispanic population
of this country and to better
represent the collection,
the Luso-Hispanic collection in this
institution, which is the largest
and finest Hispanic
collection in the world.
And to bring attention to that,
not only for the Hispanic-Americans
of this country, but for all of the
world and all the Americas, really.
And the third part of
this initiative was
to better represent the Hispanic
population within the institution
of the Library of Congress.
So this has been a very busy year
for the Hispanic Working Group.
And I think a very productive year.
And this is really a
product of their efforts.
I want to say a little
bit about the program.
You know, a vibrant American
theatre, which celebrates and stars
and serves Hispanics, has been
flourishing in this country probably
since the mid-19th Century.
And that's more than 150 hears.
But in fact, very few contemporary
American historians have written
about it or know about
or have recorded it.
Certainly, little of that story has
been recorded in any of the annals
of American theatre history even.
And now come these two scholar, Tony
Mata [phonetic] and Ralf Remshardt
to correct that oversight and
to rescue a really vivid slice
of history, the history of New
York's dynamic Latino Theatre
over the course of
the past 50 years.
They call it the Theatre
of Rice and Beans.
The documentary you're about to see
and hear represents a major
corrective and one that we want
to honor here at the
Library of Congress.
We hope that you appreciate
its broader cultural context,
the sweeping infusion of the
Hispanic arts that Professor Mata's
and Professor Remshardt
very moving film represents,
especially as they engage in
conversation with two giants
of the Washington D.C.'s
storied GALA Theatre here
in D.C. [foreign language].
We're very fortunate
to have these very.
[ Applause ]
Very fortunate to have these very
engaged witnesses join us tonight
in a tribute to the wider story.
Now Roberto Slazar who is with
the Hispanic Working Group will be
introducing our speakers
in a moment.
But first I want to make a few
acknowledgments, if you'll allow me.
Dr. Billington.
This was his idea.
This evening was his idea.
And it is really an example
of the kind of passion
that Dr. Billington has
brought as librarian,
investing this institution with
his vision of the humanities
and a conviction that the study
of humanities that knowledge
that reading makes us
all better human beings.
And his leadership in my
view has been characterized
by a very keen acuity of
-- about cultural issues.
And I have always appreciated
as a Hispanic myself
in particular his appreciation for
the broader story of the Americas.
So thank you, Dr. Billington,
for all you have done.
And let me just enumerate
a few things
in the past year that he has done.
He has named a U.S. poet
laureate, Juan Felipe Herrera,
who is the first Hispanic
ever to be a poet laureate
of the United States of America.
He has three of the Living Legend
Awards that were given in 2013,
2015, and next year
2016 are to Hispanics.
The first one was to Miguel Leon
Portilla, a wonderful linguist,
a really enormously important
historian, anthropologist,
linguist who virtually single
handily rescued the language
Nahuatl, which is the
language of the Maya
and recorded it for all time.
And he was given a
Living Legend Award.
On November 2, Marta Casals
Istomin, a magnificent contributor
to the arts and to music.
In not only in this country, but
around the world, in the Americas
and around the world will be
given the Living Legend Award.
And next spring Mario Vargas
Llosa, I hope you've heard of him,
Peruvian novelist,
Nobel Prize winner
who will be receiving
a Living Legend Award
from the Library of Congress.
And Dr. Billington has always
had a keen eye for Mexico,
our neighbor, our closest neighbor.
In many ways not only our
neighbor but our sibling.
And someone who is very
much a part of our family.
So for all of these things,
thank you Dr. Billington.
And thank you to Margery
Billington as well for her work
so many years [inaudible] and wife,
really, of the institution itself.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
I want to acknowledge, also, David
Mao who is our acting Librarian
of Congress, who is the
host of this evening.
And the chief of staff
Robert Newlen,
thank you so much for
all your support.
[ Applause ]
There are three people
who were very instrumental
in bringing this together, Angela
Kinney, there she is over there
with the Hispanic Working Group.
[ Applause ]
Francesco Macias [phonetic]
in the back of the room.
[ Applause ]
Catalina Lomas, I don't
know if you are here.
Catalina has also helped very much.
And of course, what you'll see
in the program that it says
that I am the chair of the
Hispanic Working Group.
Well, the chair of the Hispanic
Working Group is actually
here tonight.
I'm the former chair.
And I want to introduce
Avelia Rubiala [phonetic]
who is the new chair.
[ Applause ]
Now without further ado, Roberto
will introduce our speakers.
>> I do have the distinct privilege
of introducing our speakers
who after the film screening
will treat us, I believe,
to what will be a lively discussion
among the film's producers,
Tony Mata, Ralf Remshardt,
who will also be joined
by two legendary figures of
Hispanic cultural seen here
in Washington D.C. Hugo
Medrano and Abel Lopez.
Theatre of Rice and Beans
is actually the product
of an organic collaboration between
Tony Mata and Ralf Remshardt.
Tony Mata is the head
of musical theatre
at the University of Florida.
And he serves as an affiliate
faculty member for the Center
for Latin American Studies.
He's a multi-award winning director
and holds a Master in Fine Arts
in Musical Theatre from
San Diego State University.
Mr. Mata has directed, choreographed
and performed in over 300 plays,
musicals, operas, and
cabaret, in New York,
off-Broadway, and in
regional theatre.
Dr. Ralf Remshardt is a professor of
theatre at the University of Florida
and a graduate of the
Ludwig-Maximilians University
in Munich, Germany and the
Freie Universitat Berlin
where he received a Master of Arts
in German Literature
and Theatre Studies.
A native of Berlin, he first
came to the United States
on a Flubright Scholarship, and he
completed his Ph.D. in Dramatic Arts
at the University of
California Santa Barbara.
Dr. Remshardt has lectured and
delivered papers nationally
and internationally at conferences
in Canada, Germany, Great Britain,
the Netherlands, Portugal,
Spain, Greece,
Russia, China, Chile, and India.
Also joining tonight's discussion we
have Hugo Medrano who has directed
over 100 productions and produced
several shows since the founding
of the Theatre GALA in 1976.
A native of Argentina, Mr.
Medrano studied theatre
at the Theatre School of La Plata.
In Madrid, Spain he
studied with William Layton
and renowned directors Jose
Monleon and Miguel Narros.
The discussion this evening
will be moderated by Abel Lopez,
who is a theatre producer
and an adjunct professor
at George Mason University.
He has served as Theatre GALA's
associate producing director
for over 25 years.
Mr. Lopez has produced more than
65 shows and directed another 25,
including the company's
first hit production of Kiss
of the Spiderwoman that
won numerous awards.
You'll find a brief
biography for each
of these distinguished
gentleman in your program.
And I would be remiss if I didn't
also acknowledge another very
special guest who is here with us
this evening the other co-founder
of GALA Theatre, Rebecca Medrano.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
>> Keeping it theatre, Latina
Theatre in New York City
for four years, he
started this [inaudible].
>> I agree.
>> And then people say,
well why are you doing it?
Nobody's putting a gun on my
chest to say you have to do that.
I do that because I want it.
I do that because it gives
me enormous pleasure.
>> I think that what we're doing
is enriching the cultural life
of this country.
>> Latino is [inaudible].
The moment that [inaudible]
start to become different,
then you're going to be different.
>> These theatres, the three
theatres, have allowed us
to just be human beings, not have
to define ourselves by our identity
because our identity's only
one part of our humanity.
>> I would definitely
express my gratitude
for the kind of work they've done.
And for the gift they've
offered to the American Theatre.
They are the pioneers.
>> Is it 40 years?
I mean, it's a tremendous
amount of time.
And that her theatre has survived.
She just introduced us to the
world, our poets, our writers.
And she's still doing it.
She's still doing it.
>> I would like to tell those
three pioneers thank you for being
so far ahead of the curve.
And for shouting our voices when
no one was listening to our voices.
When we were still
struggling to get work.
For planting a flag in the sand.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> [inaudible] it provides a
historical [inaudible] for the work
of the Latino Theatre artists
I think in this country
and three very significant pioneers
who are focused in New York.
But we can also touch on what
was also happening in California
with [inaudible] started
about the same time.
GALA here in Washington D.C. There
was a theatre in Boston, also,
that was started about
the same period of time.
But I think that the piece really,
the documentary also touched
on a lot of issues
that really could come
under the state of Latino theatre.
You know, and some of the
issues that they were dealing
with as pioneers [inaudible], Louis
Valdez [phonetic] were also dealing
with as well is what
is the relationship
between the art and the audience.
You know, how do you
continue the work?
What is Latino theatre?
What is the importance of
the language or the question
of what does language play a
key role in this [inaudible]?
Where the language is
culture or is just semantics.
Also, the importance of creating
space for to develop the work
where it's being understood
that where to come from has
to have a context for that to be
able to develop something has to be
like to provide an environment in
which someone understands the role
that he plays in society.
So I think I really
touch on a lot of this.
But I'm also curious
as to why you want --
you hinted at it at the very
beginning of the documentary
about being in New York and going
to New York about you as an artist,
why this project was
important to you.
>> I'll tell you.
It was because they were the
surrogate parents to so many of us
when we arrived to New York,
not just me but so many of us.
And they were not only
surrogate parents to all of us,
they were also great teachers.
I had wonderful opportunities to
work as an actor and as a director
in Miriam's Theatre and to assist
Rene Bush [phonetic] as a director.
And so he highly influenced me as a
director, just being his assistant
and getting to be on stage as
an actor with him and working
at Intar [phonetic] with
Maria Repornaz [phonetic]
in the playwrights lab.
So having been in New York all
those years working with them
and having a conversation
with Ralf after he got
out of class one afternoon.
And he said you know, I
have some students that want
to do some research on
these three theatres,
and there's virtually
nothing out there.
And you know these three people,
and I said well you're good
with the camera, let's do something.
Let's -- I'll have
a dinner with them.
Let's get them all together
and start with the dinner
because I really thought if
I can get the three of them
because they were also
getting up in their years,
and I knew that if we didn't
capture some of the history
that like Marie said has
been omitted in a lot
of theatre history
books that this part
of American theatre history was
going to vanish and be gone.
And I didn't want people
to read this information
in a theatre history book.
I wanted them to get it from them.
And I wanted all of the people
to understand the great influence
they had on multiple generations.
So that was important to depict
in the film was all of the people
and the generations
that they impacted.
But so when Ralf said that
to me, I said all right,
well I'll organize the dinner,
and we'll get them together,
which was chore in and of
itself to get three people
of their caliber to agree on a date.
And then my dear friend Dave
had offered his apartment,
who's here tonight in New
York, and said all right,
we can have it in his apartment.
And we'll gather everybody
together and have a dinner.
And from that dinner, which was
about three hours of shooting,
we said thank God, okay
we have that, right, Ralf?
And --
>> We had the film at that point.
>> Yeah. And then --
>> We couldn't have been more wrong.
>> No. Because went from the dinner
what we started to discover is,
I said, well now we have
to get some of these people
that they're talking about.
So when, you know, to try to
get somebody like Nilo Cruz
who just won the Pulitzer
Prize or Lin-Manuel Miranda
who just won the Tony for
In the Heights and trying
to schedule interviews
with them while we're kind
of have our full-time
academic schedule and directing
and all the things that we do.
And I might also add that during
this process, we were applying
for grants and were getting nothing
because we were not professional
documentarians, by the way.
We had never done this before.
So every time we would apply for
a grant, they would say, well,
you've never done this before,
so we're not going to --
even Latino Public Broadcasting
did not give us a dime.
And we applied twice.
And even though this was such an
important story, they said oh no.
You know, it's not
worthy or whatever it is.
And so --
>> I think they had a justified
skepticism, which is when we talked
to our editor, who by
the way we really have
to acknowledge Dennis Gatson.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> Terrific, terrific.
In this process because
he gave much of his --
much of his time for free or for
very little money to help us.
But when we talked to him, he was a
very experience documentary maker.
He said 80 or 90 percent
I forget what --
anyways a very high
number of documentaries
that start never, ever get finished.
And so, so the skepticism of PBS
was, you know, understandable.
Why would they think that
we would finish this?
Why did we think we would finish?
And so, you know, somehow
it got made.
>> But I think that the sheer --
this really was a true labor of love
because we were determined.
We were driven by the fact that
we knew we had to finish it
because we knew we wanted them to
see it before anything happened.
And we know that Rene had gotten
rather frail, had gotten sick.
And so that pushed us
even further to we have
to finish this, we
have to finish this.
And so we had our first screening,
and the film was an
hour and twenty minutes.
And we had it at Tribeca
Cinemas in New York last year,
and thankfully they
were all able to come.
Rene almost didn't make it even
the day before we weren't sure
because he had been in the hospital.
But they were all able to attend.
And Chita Rivera came.
And a bunch of the community came
to support and watch the film.
And they were just so happy
just to see their lives,
I think, on the screen, you know.
And what they've done and the
legacy that they've left with all
of us was truly, it was a gift.
It was very, very exciting
for Ralf and myself to think
that we could even take on
something that was incredibly,
something we had never done
but just sheer passion and will
to finish this film
and get it out there.
And so -- and it really
was Ralf and Dennis Gatson
who were absolutely incredible,
the three of us were just --
we couldn't have done it without
Dennis because like Ralf said he's,
you know, he had done
so many documentaries.
And he gave in kind
so many of his hours.
Because I want to thank
the University of Florida
for allowing us to get these small
little grants that we would apply
for that would give us
$1500 here and $2,000 here
so that we could travel and
get the interviews done.
Just very basic.
We weren't Ken Burns.
And we didn't have millions of
dollars, and we didn't have a team
of people to do this for us.
>> [inaudible] reflect actually
[inaudible] pioneers because --
>> Well, exactly, yeah.
>> You're pioneering actually the
same way because I mean is was
to their persistence that
actually created [inaudible].
>> Shoestring.
>> Shoestring and they
did everything and stuff.
I wanted to ask Hugo because I
know you're a colleague of Rene
and Intar and Miriam as well.
How did what you saw in the film
mirror or what GALA, your experience
with GALA, starting GALA
as an individual artist,
and then the relationship
to community and language,
the issues of language
and how you relate to some
of the questions that addressed?
>> So, so, similar that actually
[inaudible] I was looking
at them we were thinking,
what way we different?
Because we are some way different.
But we have exactly the
same background, exactly.
I was listen to Rene about his
dreams about what he wanted to do.
The fact that he wanted to do in
Spanish the I was listen to --
>> Miriam.
>> -- Miriam about trying
to go out, take the theatre
out of the inside theatre.
And there so things that that's
exactly what we were doing.
The same thing with the language.
This kind of decision and security
about doing it in Spanish only
or in English to whom we
talk to in terms of audience.
What is our audience?
And then when I saw
really our difference
in the question of the audience.
I think that GALA, first of all,
GALA is the abbreviation for Group
of Artistas from Latin American.
That's why it's GALA.
Isn't that a wonderful place
to dance or [inaudible].
But yes, it's a group of
Latin American artists,
which is a conduction of
many, many different nations.
Many different type of artists.
And they don't have the unity,
identity as these people
that we saw tonight.
As the Caribbean group, as the
Nuyoricans as the Chicanos,
which are not here but you
know it's another big group.
As the Cuban American in Miami.
So we are so heterogeneous
so diverse that from
in one side is wonderful
because it's very rich.
It's very, very much
culture in many ways.
But at same time we don't have that
type of unity, that type of focus
on who are we referring to.
It's too general being
Latin American.
Now it is.
So it is very difficult
at every level.
At the level of the administration.
At the level of development.
At the level of creating a
company, maintaining a company.
At the level of choosing
the season every season.
To whom we put this play.
Is the play exciting for some sector
of our audience because we have
to divide our audience in sectors.
You know, we are referring
to Anglos.
And we're referring
to Latino Americanos.
to Hispanic Americans.
So it is -- it is a very difficult.
And in that sense we're
different [inaudible].
But in terms of experience
in terms of the past,
we have the same experience
starting from zero.
Trying to create a
company, training a company,
you'd be part of that
whole process too.
So and stage too [inaudible].
But yeah, that is.
That is what [inaudible].
>> I was also struck by the point
that as pioneers [inaudible] same
way I think is their committed
to the next generation of artists.
>> Absolutely.
>> And the importance that it wasn't
about just creating an
institution for the sake of vanity.
But the importance of willing to
the creative process and how much
of their efforts has been
about commissioning work,
whether it's for their own
companies or their own ensembles
or commissioning artists
or now trying
to support a particular
artist like [inaudible].
But that is really important to
them, the next generation I think.
>> I think that when you look
at how many young Latinos
in this country don't speak Spanish,
it's really important that you look
at theatre from a broader
perspective because you don't want
to lose your identify
and your culture.
But yet you have to think about,
which is what Lynn
did so brilliantly.
I think that Miriam, Max, and
Rene and Hugo and so many pioneers
who start these companies
from the ground up.
And then you have some
of the younger generation
like Lin-Manuel say, you know,
they reap the rewards, you know.
I think it was -- it was
the idea that every one
of those companies would launch
a show to Broadway in terms
of a musical and all of
those kinds of ideas.
But it was a struggle,
and it was hard.
And I think that when you have
somebody like Lin-Manuel say well
to identify how to tell the story
about our people not in the sense
of West Side Story, but in the
sense of community and the sense
about family and love and culture
that embraces our communities.
I think that's what made that show
so brilliant is that he was able
to capture that with the language
and the bilingually in the music
and the songs as well as the script.
And I think it was told from a
perspective of family and unity.
And so I think that show really
is a milestone in our community.
And I'm not saying it just
because I'm a musical theatre
director and specialist.
I think that it really did something
really special to our community
in terms of telling a story
that was about family.
It wasn't about what we
do in terms of violence
or stereotyping or
all of the things.
And I think that that's
slowly changing.
But I think it's a broader
conversation from the fact
that often we're not included
at the table in the industry.
I think that many times
that we are left out and not
because they don't understand
where we're coming from
or sometimes I don't
believe it's intentional.
I just don't think they
know how to include us.
And so when I see film and I see TV
shows continuously and the omission
of our people sometimes,
it really --
and there's an attempt for
that to happen, it's still not
where it should be at this
point because of the fact
that we represent such a
large geographic community,
and we are a great influence
financially to this country.
>> At the same time,
though, what is similar,
I think about all these individuals
Hugo [inaudible] is they didn't wait
for somebody to invite
them to the table.
>> No.
>> Right.
>> They didn't wait for somebody
to invite them to the table.
[inaudible] they decided.
They saw a need, and
then they addressed it.
>> That's right.
>> Because if you think of their
history, their history's almost
as old as the original
theatre movement.
>> Completely.
>> But the perception of that
theatre, of these theatres
and the two is very different.
>> Very.
>> Because they're not
necessarily at the table.
But it's not because they -- but
they didn't wait to be invited.
And I think that that's a
lesson that we can't forget.
>> Absolutely.
>> One of the things you pointed
out, I think, is quite right,
which is instantly, as soon as they
had established these institutions,
they also understood the need for
perpetuation and for continuity.
And so the training units
were instituted very early on.
The playwrights units
were instituted very early
on in recognition of the embattled
nature of any theatre that is,
you know, that's not
mainstream theatre.
And so that's one of the
things they've done very,
very successfully.
Now obviously there's been
several people who've emerged
who are now big names.
But just to keep workshops going.
To keep playwrights writing.
To just kind of spread that
sensibility in a way that's kind
of immeasurable is, I think,
an enormous achievement,
you know, apart from that.
So when they ask what's next,
they really were very
much the generators,
the progenitors of
what's coming next.
It's not something --
it's not an idle question.
It's really kind of, you know,
it's a hand over in some ways.
And for us, you know, yeah --
for us, we also felt that we were
just able to get them at the moment
at which they -- there was a
certain maturity [inaudible]
to these institutions,
but they were ready
to think about handing it over.
You know, I mean these institutions
are all so very connected
to strong personalities
as they have to be.
And you know, so it's very,
very difficult, obviously,
to then find a successor, to find --
figure out how the
institution might go on.
And -- but that thinking had
exactly started to happen.
And so that's I think why the
question immediately sort of stood
in the room as we served
the dinner, so to speak.
Tell us everything you've done.
But also tell us where
it's going, you know.
And that -- they were
ready to do that.
>> And I think that Puerto Rico
[inaudible] is already matched
with another group.
>> It is [inaudible].
>> Which is fantastic.
>> Yeah, they have a co --
they're co-producing now.
>> That's right.
So I think that's the --
>> That's what I was
going to ask you, Tony,
can you give us up
to date since then?
Because it's been a few years.
>> Well, Miriam, what happened is
that Miriam was trying to figure
out a way how to pass
the theatre on.
And she wanted to stay
very much a figurehead
because she still is very
important to the theatre,
the Puerto Rican Traveling Theatre.
So she Rosada [phonetic] and
her had established a very
strong relationship.
And so I think the idea was
that Rosada would be the person
that would run these two theatres,
and Miriam as a figurehead.
So but Rosada is the one
that's really running those two
institutions both Playwanas
[phonetic]
and the Puerto Rican
Traveling Theatre
and the programming that's
going on in these two theatres.
Rene is not involved anymore
in any of this decision making
because he's been quite ill.
And Max is having quite
a nice career in Miami,
you know, teaching and directing.
So he continues to do his work.
But I think that Lou Merana
[phonetic] is now running Intar.
And he's the new artistic director.
And he's also operating out of
a very small theatre because,
you know, Intar was on
Theatre Row for many years.
And they had a beautiful,
beautiful facility.
And they basically promised to
give it back and they never did.
And so they ended up back
in a very, very tiny space
on the Upper West Side where they're
still continuing to do theatre.
But again, with very limited
funds in hoping that somebody
that the city is going to
grant them a new space.
So it's -- I think that what we done
in some ways is just brought
these theatres to a platform
so that everybody is aware of what
they struggle to do and just like,
you know, Hugo has done, there's
so many people that have done
such amazing work in our
community to tell these stories
and develop these wonderful
young playwrights.
And so the idea was just to
not let them be forgotten
because it would have been.
>> So I was going to ask you, how
do you hope that this film is used
to keep telling that story?
>> I think one of the
things we're --
>> Because particularly I think the
importance of it is now you have,
like, scholarly material or
material that scholars can use.
>> Correct.
>> Can refer to.
>> Right. And I think that's what
we want to do is that we want to go
into the different film festivals
and continue to screen it.
And then we've already gotten
offers to show it on PBS in Florida.
And so that's why we had
to cut down to 57 minutes
because it had to be
to that standard.
And then hope is that eventually
that this documentary is shown
at every theatre appreciation
and theatre history class
across the country so that it is
a part of the curriculum of much
of the theatre history
classes, so that --
because one of our
colleagues Charlie Mitchell
who teaches these classes,
Theatre Appreciation, says please,
I can't wait until you're
able to let us use this film
because there's nothing
that I can use in my class
at this point to talk about this.
>> He actually reads several
of the plays with his students
that are mentioned here, like
the Cuban Swimmer, and so forth.
So this would be a wonderful
sort of [inaudible] of that.
Eventually, it's probably
going to --
we'll have to find some way to make
it accessible through streaming
because that's really kind of
the next mode of distribution.
So we'll have to figure
out how to do that.
>> We have a website.
And we have, of course, a way for
people to kind of view the trailer.
And eventually, my hope is that it's
available for everybody to see it.
And with the amazing technology
that we have today, I don't --
this was not about money or
making money or anything like that
for any of us, God knows.
It was really about
sharing the story.
So for me, if everybody can
see this, and if it's available
on YouTube or wherever
it is that other scholars
and students can see this.
Then I think it's worth doing
what we did because it's not --
it's really about sharing
the stories.
>> Latino playwrights too.
>> And Latino playwrights, yes.
>> Before we open it
up to the audience,
I want to touch on
a couple of things.
And that is -- or maybe Hugo
and Rebecca you might want
to chat add something
to about the context.
Because there was a context of these
theatres at this particular time
when they were being formed in
the '60s and '70s [inaudible].
Can you talk about what the
times were [inaudible] time?
And also because I just happen to
know that Anna Steal's [phonetic]
in the audience who's with the
National Endowment for the Arts,
and they had a program there
which was called Expansion Arts.
It was really important to the
birth of these theatres here.
So I think that, you know,
understanding that context
I think is important.
>> Well, I think that we founded
the theatre in the middle --
very particular time
in Washington D.C.
Because there were very particular
audience composed of basically,
I mean, audience, community,
Latino community in Washington,
who was really conform
of many people immigrants
from different countries
and their dictatorship.
So there were people with a very
high grade of education, doctors,
actors, professionals who had
to leave the country desperately
to another city and basically
Washington D.C. because many
of them were involved also in trying
to change what was going
on in Latin America.
So there was a very particular
audience, very well-educated
that needed a kind of space
where they could find out,
where they could enjoy
their own culture.
And we did plays and
we cannot afford to do
that because they were very
political, very sociopolitical.
They were written.
They were as they say in
the movie place and we broke
from Latin America, which
has a very European kind
of literature and theatre.
That never was done in Washington
D.C. I mean, at the time we were one
of the four most avant-garde
theatres when we started.
We didn't know that.
But of course less
the American audience.
So it is as they say, it is a
question of doing what you need
to do what your guts tell you.
And to that people who need it.
As you said we never thought
about the table or whatever.
We really wanted to create
this because of the need of it.
Not only the audience, our
community, but also ourselves,
this group of artists
from Latin America.
>> I want to open it up
to the audience to see
if there are any questions.
Right here.
>> Yes. Thank you for doing this.
I think it's great, and it's
great to teach future generations.
But I was wondering, you know,
I've been thinking about the idea
of language and identity.
And to see the generations that
are being born here of immigrants,
unfortunately some of them
are losing the Spanish.
They're not bilingual.
They don't know, some of them
have never been to the countries
where there parents came from.
So looking down the road,
what do you see the future
of Hispanic theatre is given that
there's this generation of kids
who don't necessarily have
that emotional and cultural tie
to language and identity?
What is the future
shaping up as you look
at both playwrights
and your audiences?
>> Tony, you go.
>> I think it's a brilliant
question.
I wish I had a way to
look into the crystal ball
to look into the future.
But I think that we're dealing
just in you know the amount of time
that I've been teaching,
which is over 20 years.
We've see a change in the
way young people think.
And so to look ten years down
the line or even five years
down the line with this
technology and the fact
that they're completely hooked
to a black screen 24/7
and cannot leave it.
That's challenge in and of itself.
Because they are multitaskers
of so many things
but cannot keep their mind on one.
And theatre is so much about focus.
And it's so much about clarity.
And it's so much about
collaboration.
It's not so much about this.
But yet, it's important to
include that because if you don't,
you start losing that,
your young audience.
So I think it's a real challenge to
figure out how theatre can continue
to develop, bring young people
in, and especially Latinos
so that stories that
they can understand.
I mean, there's the show right
now called Jane the Virgin
that everybody is watching
on television right now,
which I think is great.
And young people are watching it
because they can relate
to some of the stories.
So I think it's about trying to
figure out ways to create stories
that young people want to
come to the theatre to see.
And yet, preserving some of the
culture and some of the classics
because we don't want
to forget [inaudible]
and all the great Spanish
playwrights
or Latino playwrights
in this country.
We want to -- so it's a
balance to try to figure
out what it is they need
and how to address it
from a larger perspective.
So I'll let Hugo.
>> [inaudible] I think
that we do know is just
with being cultivating the future
ideal Latino, which is a combination
of knowledge and experience of
their own culture [inaudible] going
to the countries, original
country from the families.
Having a more or less understanding
of the language, possible,
completely understanding of the
language that would be idea.
And really conscious of
what their own culture is.
I don't think it is already.
That there is a real
conscious of being a Latino.
Because maybe I'm thinking like that
because of the subject I put before,
which is [inaudible]
community that we have here.
But yes, I believe that it's
going to be a future audience
and future Hispanic
authors that are going to be
in the mainstream, definitely.
>> But I will -- yes,
getting ready to close
because we have a reception
waiting for you guys.
And I don't want to keep you
from the food and the drinks.
But I will add -- our service
indicate at GALA that they want
to see the plays in Spanish, but
they want to receive the information
about the plays in English.
So it's something for us that
we are constantly looking at.
Because they want to see the play in
the original language it was written
because of what they get from
it physically and visually.
But they want it to technology.
They want to get the
information in English.
>> I think one of the things
that [inaudible] currently is
that they do the productions in
Spanish, and they have the earphones
so they can translate the
production in English.
[ Inaudible ]
>> And playwrights.
The question not just to
audience to goes to the future
of Latino theatre who's
writing them.
And what I think we're seeing with a
lot of Hispanic American playwrights
as well including [inaudible]
who came to GALA.
We did his show in English.
And then afterwards he said, I
wish I had written it in Spanish.
So there's an awareness
among those playwrights
who are all the second generation.
What am I missing?
I'm still that being.
I still think.
The difficulty is, who's going
to produce them in Spanish.
They get to a level where they
don't want to be produced, you know,
at GALA because you know they
want bigger and they need bigger.
And there should be more
companies who produce them,
but they have to do them in English.
And that's a question of
not having expansion arts,
not having enough endowment money,
not having enough stake money,
not have enough attention.
It goes in 30-year cycles.
When we started, we got a six --
you know, Miss Manners gave
us a six-column headline
for a show [foreign language] that
nobody even knew because it was in.
Because Spanish was in.
Bilingualism was in.
You had to speak Spanish in school.
You took it 30 years ago, right?
Now it wasn't [inaudible].
So I think it's going
to come around.
I think as fashion does.
>> I think there are authors
like [inaudible] Washington D.C.
That they really have
been successful
in Spanish and an English.
And Karen [phonetic]
[inaudible] writes in English
but immediately she does
translations of her own things.
>> Karen just [inaudible] opened
there in season and did [phonetic]
at GALA last season
in Spanish, last fall.
I want to thank you all.
I want to thank our
guests and our panelists.
[ Applause ]
I want to acknowledge again
the Library of Congress,
the Librarian of Congress, and
the interim Librarian of Congress
and the association here
[inaudible] putting this on.
It's been of great
benefit to the community.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.